Just in case you can't read it, that's Blast Off Video.
And you probably can't read that one, that's an A.A. Network production.
Practice my sword skills in the training room.
Um, would you like to help me?
Gonna chop into a little tiny piece.
Now get back in bed, it's not time for you to wake up.
Tigger, don't wake up the children.
Or Dad.
Oh, I just wanted some fun in the morning.
That's what Tiggers do, of course.
Just sit there and don't bother the cake.
We're having pie and cake.
The cake's too small.
Is it honey cake?
Pie is honey.
The cake is strawberry.
Is it a very small cake for a very small animal?
Jumping through the room.
And bouncing.
Sorry about that, Tigger.
Morning.
I need to sharpen my own sword.
I'll go this way.
Is it a special day today?
And if you...
Let me just tell you.
The cake is strawberry.
Pie is honey.
Now quiet down.
She's gonna wake up all the babies.
The babies are...
When are songs up yet?
Because, um, she went out...
Get away, Doctor Senora.
All the hustle and bustle in the morning.
Always makes a lot of noise.
Yeah, I'm gonna wake them up.
Toa and Taronga are never up.
I wonder why.
Some of them get lost in their tubes, and others just plain get occupied with something.
Well, they can't...
Hey, Bella.
Whatcha cooking?
I got...
Sure.
A guy in a dragon.
And here's Baby Melis.
Let's go get your sister.
And the cake.
You think he's won some pancake shish kebabs?
Yes.
I think he will.
I have honey.
See you others.
Football.
Okay, I should go to bed.
Okay, I'll play. I'm not used to playing, but...
Now, what's going to be the football this time?
Lose a change. A quarter.
Wonderful.
To break.
Right here.
Does anybody else want to come down and play football?
Funstrike.
He's rushing to line up.
On the field then. First.
On here.
It will be the audience, and then the next game you'll have to be picked.
Who wants to pick Boar?
I'm not attacking on anybody.
Maybe Sam just pulled him out.
You mean?
Of course, Adam did come down to...
direct.
Now, he went to an island, right?
Yeah, that's right.
For a vacation, remember?
I guess you're going to have to pick another one.
Boar left. Maybe Jess on here.
The Powerpuff Girls on one team.
One team.
The other team, and everybody else.
Um, there's one girl here.
Two home.
Okay, you can be the three stands over here.
It's very hard being a badger for life.
Does anybody here want to play?
I'm not a piglet. You want to.
You'll be in the audience until later.
Until further notice, I should say.
Anybody?
One, two, three, four, five, six, ten...
Boy, Tommy will marvel at the new mask I got him.
...twelve, ten, twelve...
Not to mention our new one.
Snowy can contain powers, and they're also good.
Okay.
Those consider them a beauty.
Ready to play football.
Boar's going to make a call.
Now, let's go.
I told you guys not to do football this time of day.
I wonder why Dr. Spear isn't up yet.
What's up, then?
I'm like, you go get him.
No.
Bella, you'll go tell Stacy.
No, Alma, go tell her.
Okay?
I'll go get Alma and her badger.
Alma the badger.
Cut your hair.
Hey, hon, what time's the...
Just a normal day.
Why can't I just sleep?
I'm busy.
Why is everybody talking?
Special speech.
I don't really want to sleep.
Come on, get out of bed.
Or rip your arm off.
Oh, damn.
Really, the pain.
I'm in.
I'm winding up so far.
Honey, that's...
I've never used a sword or anything as delicate as a cake.
Can I please have a normal knife?
Here.
It's such a hard...
You guys want to play golf?
I've grown up, I suppose.
And you got it.
Now, the chemical looks terrible.
Okay, you're only supposed to call on this hotline if you're calmed down.
Oh, I'm in.
Here comes another call.
Yes?
I'm going to call about it.
There's your note.
Call.
Can I talk to Bob?
Yeah, this is Wade Young from the hip-hop.
I think you had called about an article.
Yeah.
Oh.
Yep.
Yes.
And you are starting to get a handle on this problem?
No.
Well, just calm down.
We'll solve the problem then.
Okay, what's the problem?
Say it more clearly.
Your voice is so shaky.
Okay.
It's...
It's the ultimate evil, and you say he can beat us.
Well, no evil has been able to beat us before, but we've been hit by evil pretty good.
Yeah, we're going.
It's Makuta.
He's escaped.
Escaped.
Yeah.
No.
Don't...
Never underestimate your enemy.
I've always learned that.
Oh, really?
Yeah, I'm pulling on my battle boots.
Now I'm getting my teeth hurt.
Okay.
Now, let's go.
Anybody ready?
Yes, you have to go.
Well, this time it's important.
This time this guy's pretty powerful, and it's like a big guy.
So, you're coming with me.
Let's go.
There's his lair.
We'll be there soon.
Everybody okay?
Certainly no place like this is.
Huh?
It's a basket.
I hate baskets.
Stop it.
We're wrong.
This stupid guy captured us.
I don't know.
The tower's going to have to battle.
Your evil plans would lead to something like this.
Then you would have escaped.
Now.
One and four.
All.
Hey, Mwaka.
Conrad.
Let's take care of these guys.
Sure, Dad.
I have something to say about it.
You, Makuta.
Let's go.
Mwaka and Conrad.
You must take off their masks first.
They'll never survive.
You'll be right in the middle of it.
You must take off the mask.
It's time to battle again with the Toa.
Stupid masks.
I can't get off until they're my sister.
So I can probably be...
A Toa?
They've never defeated me.
I don't care.
Just do each other.
Protect your own masks.
You don't got the right brain to defeat me.
Lost one life.
Toa of two lives.
Haha.
Toa of only one.
The last one's in the super family.
I win, Doctor Senor.
Don't worry.
He knocked out.
But Wig wins.
But he doesn't have any masks.
Kaliweg.
You always keep forgetting to get your own masks.
Hello.
I'm sorry, but this one can't move.
This is my weakest.
So, you'll probably get defeated anyway.
The trap.
We continue.
I just happen to be one of the best fighters of the Toa.
Toa of two lives.
Well, they're probably weak to fire.
So I'll use Kanra.
My sword can freeze anything it touches.
I don't believe that.
Haha.
That leaves me...
Ready to destroy you.
No!
He defrosted already.
That's what you get for being evil.
Since you have been destroyed, you will be locked in your...
Until somebody rescues you.
But that won't happen.
To lock you in.
You mean a snipe or something?
I locked in.
To challenge me.
You are just a disgrace.
You are never, ever powerful.
But you're kind.
Unlike the other Toa.
Well, most of them are kind.
But you're the kindest.
I was looking for more of a...
A...
Better battle!
If you will.
Well I am a better battle.
You just think I'm not?
Well...
Look at your size.
And this case holds both me and my Toa brother.
I am Pohatu.
I start with the introductions.
Woka.
Kanra.
Uttag-
Oh yeah?
Well I'm going to beat you anyway.
because I got a super powerful hammer where is it right let's just back I need
a new head you lose lives yeah when I lose my head I my mask goes with it
aren't you attacking the flea brain please are you'll stay frozen for a
minute darn it I can't get it did you say that
much information what's wrong with you get out gold man what time to put on my
gold mask and whip your butt are you doing attack him get the gold have it
stick it down in there damn it he's got one more life he's going to get the best
put your mask back on he's going for my mask I'll put your ass back on and
battle it
I'll rip your hides off yeah I sound evil
wow and look I got a before he does that backflip thing don't install your mask
wow my compassion is rock hard shouldn't use that thrash move I've only got one
life left use it correctly all you go walk up defend your mask camera attack
mask
what I'm gonna need my silver mask make of the deal I got super defense
darn it I only got one life left but oh he'll count it'll countless to
feet that can hook on a ouch
shot B packaging
oh my god this is fours were ways I'll take accusations is the only one who
stood in my way to taking over axy now okay oh man should I have it up the tree
the world and I'll put the rest of them locked in their cases to lock you in
three them in Karana you are now all locked in and that means Tahu the battle
with me to me they are the me see how easy he is the fire will go out the time
has come Tahu battle with me not get my gold mask on you have a gold mask too
yes I do what'd you think yeah no water and most power my sword is like a whip
but it carries fire I can defeat all elements why aren't you attacking unlike
the other Toa I have six lives six lives
well so do I I have more more than 100 yeah but what happens if I take crime
out I lose a lot darn it I thought each mask came off that I thought that every
mask Kate that came off it would make it lose a life but it's something much
worse what is evil becoming these days there's a lot cuz my head came off with
it
always happens nothing will defeat me haha just completely nothing my sword
will vanquish all on the bad side I sound evil too this is ready go back
into your case what you said that was a Makuta we go into my case you will go
into your case you will go into your case you will go into your case you will go
in reverse
forever
it is defeated
you can collect them both on the
cloud of goodness for Crime
around any bad guy who was powerful and they tell me on the good side
will take a while for the evil onwards
but I have defeated some family gooodbye
super family
bye bye guys
Your reign of good has come to an end, and my reign of evil has just begun!
Got any cough drops?
Now I can finally come out of this hot place.
The real Makuta comes out.
It's good to be out again.
What should I conquer first?
Hmm, wait a second.
I should conquer the Super Family.
But they've already did that.
I should conquer Mata Nui first, since the Toa do not go there anymore.
But I could enslave the Bohrok.
That's true.
Leech-like creatures that come out of their eggs.
Driven by a force that they cannot explain.
I heard that in a comic once.
I think I took the cough drop.
You will have nothing to do about it.
The Toa!
Help the Super Family!
I will destroy Makuta!
The Toa are my friends!
Where could the Super Family be?
Well, it doesn't really matter that much.
But I have to destroy Makuta.
But where could Makuta be?
What did Makuta want to conquer?
Ah, he wanted to conquer the Super Family.
But he also wanted to conquer the world.
So that means, could I go to the Super Family?
Or should they come to me and battle?
Should I go to them, or should they come to me?
Is it true that the Super Family is good?
Or is it bad?
Where could the Super Family be?
I know they might be where they battled last.
But first, I must go find the other Bohrok.
So they can help me defeat Makuta.
Ah, first I must find the Fire Bohrok.
Hey, wait a minute.
I'm the Fire Bohrok.
Here I go!
My cape.
I have to drain our mask.
Get a mask.
He's a baby.
And don't talk out of my shade.
Get you a cape.
Why is my sister over here?
Because she just got hired.
We've got to figure out a way to destroy Makuta so he doesn't slave us again.
Because Mata knew he used to be peaceful.
But now it isn't.
I know.
There has to be a way.
We'll figure out one soon enough.
For now, let's just keep about our chores.
And once we get free time and lunch, we'll talk about it.
Alright.
Because nobody watches us at lunch.
Here I am.
Underground.
Good thing I turned on my night vision so I can see down here.
You can too.
Hmm.
Where could he be?
There's a cave over there.
Maybe I can get to it.
Sure.
I will get over there.
It's Newvok!
Now bite him.
Now he's good.
Let me bite that again.
The next Bohrok for me to find is probably...
Is Kopaka.
Um.
Kopaka is the Ice Bohrok.
So she will probably be on top of a mountain.
Using my...
Flame.
I will burn a...
I will burn a pass to her.
I think.
If I can find out where she is.
Now let's take him.
Ouch.
Now that really gave me a headache.
Let's see.
I found myself.
Kopaka.
I mean.
Ko...
Korok.
And Newvok.
Now I need to find Galak.
Um.
Uh.
Lavok.
And Polarok.
Polarok's next.
Bohrok rock!
Hey look.
There's Polarok.
Maybe I can climb to him.
And I gotta start there.
Uh.
This place is uncomfortably hot.
But I'm used to hot.
Alright.
Let's go.
Phew.
Mm-hmm.
I ain't fit for climbing these days.
Maybe I'll try a different approach.
Yeah.
That's what I'll do.
I'll try a different approach.
I've got to find a different way up there.
I know.
This is perfect.
There it is.
I'll get up there.
That little spot right there.
That's where I'll start.
Maybe I'll use the Tarzan move right about there.
Made it.
Whoa.
This will work.
Man.
This thing's going to be hurting me for days.
Ugh.
The jungle.
I'm at the jungle.
Hey.
Wait a second.
What's that up there?
It's the Bohrok.
Man.
This is the first one where I spot the Bohrok.
Right away.
Now.
To get up to him, I need to head all the way to that point.
But before I need to get, I need to get past those funny looking fruits.
But first I've got to use the Tarzan move to get up to the vine.
Here I go.
I need to get to there.
It's going to take me hours.
Man.
It's really bright up here.
I'm right in front of the sun.
And now I need to jump.
Two.
Lay back.
It's been pretty hard to make.
And get.
Better be a pretty powerful Bohrok or I'll say I got ripped off.
Well.
There she is.
Galak.
The best.
The last Bohrok to be gotten.
Here I go.
I need to kick Makuta's butt.
Sensation.
And chain.
To talk with Makuta.
We've got to figure out a good way to destroy them.
Let's all transform into one big flying robot.
Alright.
Let's go.
Let's leave these numbskulls so called peas.
Like we would ever let them have it.
Now.
So called peas.
We will transform.
Wait.
Your arm fell off.
Alright.
Stop what you're doing.
And we'll go talk with Makuta.
Dun dun dun.
Who could that be at this time of morning?
I am Makuta.
And nothing bothers me in the morning.
Who is that?
I only see you as one.
Because I'm a Tawanga Kaita.
You have combined as one.
We have combined as one.
Well come forward and battle me if that's what you came for.
Stupid leg.
Let's battle.
Scratcher.
Scratch off my mask.
You are no match for me.
Defeated.
This guy is too hard.
Ha.
I even got it.
I haven't got even.
I haven't even got.
Gotten to my most powerful form yet.
Ha.
I have defeated all that is good.
Now I shall rule.
Nothing to say about it.
We have come to settle with you Makuta.
Well.
Who's up first?
Settle with you.
I know that as a Bohrok I'm not able to defeat you by myself.
But I will try my best.
Ha.
All six Bohrok aren't enough to destroy me.
There are many other Bohrok.
Oh yeah?
Well.
Something will take care of them.
The evil Bohrok.
But for now I must take care of you.
Let's battle.
Alright.
Get your Krona.
Defensive Krona.
Well.
You should be destroyed.
Let me quickly choose my offensive.
Krona.
To take care of you.
Ha.
You're too easy.
Felony must fight for power.
I have failed but I have taken one of his forms and destroyed one of his forms.
I have beaten his first form.
But I have failed.
Since he has destroyed my first half I'm gonna have to go to my second part.
Now you will have to settle with my middle part.
Middle part?
it just has the same number of maskas as any other part oh well it may be
powerful but I think you'll be able to defeat it huh evil trap thinking that I
might win against it no way that is impossible so now I must get this part
hmm attack him that was good stupid mask I've lost one life and now I have to use
my next one what's that as my mother always said now play unfair honey that
was unfair as my mother always said if they play unfair play unfair right
back to him well you didn't take my mask off failed also uh I've failed you Galak
why don't you take my mask off
we battle now let's go get him i mean get her she knocked off her first mask without even having a
challenge get her she's gonna sting it fools attack her how do you know i'm gonna stay at
bird brain it's different stupid you never attack job just keep it up make sure her corona falls out
she's only got one and thank you cheater oh so it's not really cheating but first i gotta fix my
head ow man that hurt don't you wash yourself come to settle with you makuta that's what they
all say but i'm the one with the lots of crime darn it now which karma should i use first i'll
use this battle this thing's ugly trauma but my defense is pretty low uh all right there has to
be some way to even touch it i'm gonna have to go for my purple color he's taking it too easily
well you're dead weak man that he's harder on me than the other bow rocket
hmm could be you one to one is that fair how about two to one i'll tell you one thing
hey you took your mask off yeah but unfortunately you're dead meat i am but now you are dead meat
not on sting attack you're paralyzed now now i can just take your mask off without you attacking me
i can't be attacks i'm the first bowrock to do that my stinger had fell off darn it i won't be
able to paralyze you now you took off all four of my masks yes i have defeated your form now
to take care of your middle gentle hey you took off her mask pork
Get him!
Stupid thing!
They're hurting.
Get it back on!
I cannot go on.
It failed also.
Bo Rock.
Ha!
All of the Bo Rock have been destroyed at this point.
Too soft.
Weakling.
Rock's a weakling.
Korok's a weakling.
Ha!
How come she doesn't bite like the other Bo Rock?
Because I'm more smarter.
Gonna beat them.
Yeah, but you just lost your chrono and you charged right into my back.
Leave a breeze in the morning.
Thing came off.
So I don't want to get my Sturdy on my back.
And that hurt.
This is the same as my white one except it's blue.
Go a little bit slower this time so I can get a good grip.
Never gonna get these things off.
Not one for too long.
That's wrong, Fab.
I'm gonna fall asleep if I keep it off too much.
Too long.
Fuck her chrono out.
At least not too long.
Never chrono out before the middle's knocked out.
Protect the last mask.
Protect it.
You're gonna fall.
It isn't gonna fail.
Ha!
You don't even have a chrono and you're gonna fall asleep soon.
Thank you for reminding me.
That's all I say.
My favorite one.
Let's watch the action.
I get to taste the action.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Attack her.
She attacked you, Makuta.
Now that is...
You're dead meat, Makuta.
Actually, you don't have to do that.
You don't have any meat.
If you did, it'd taste bad.
Oh, well.
Gotta get rid of you.
Let's battle.
Leader Bohrok.
No other Bohrok is as powerful as me.
They may have more chrono, but I will beat, um, any tricky thing, aren't you?
This thing's going back in.
Do I hear...
Oh!
I must hear a weakling.
Do you hear a weakling?
Who are you calling weakling?
This guy really is a challenge.
As Dr. Señora was saying, I'm a weakling.
Why didn't you just do that?
Well, Makuta always said...
Or what did he say?
Well, my pals talk about it.
They say, ever underestimate your enemy.
Yeah, that's what it is.
Spotted you, Makuta.
Not quite.
Master going back on.
That's cheating.
Oh, no it is not.
Hey, it isn't that going the other one.
Want some more?
Be the nightmare of your life, Tanaka.
Hey, what did he just do?
Makuta, what?
But I've got tricks up my sleeve, too.
But I dare not use them, because you'd be whining.
What are they?
For a kaita, toa kaita, revive toa.
Maybe that'd be the best one.
No, you cannot revive them.
Unless my cron is released, which will never happen.
Ah, ha, ha, ha.
Oh, well, just shut up. Let's battle.
I can't even see. Where are the bear?
Well, you can move freely, and these guys can't.
But now they can.
How do you like that?
You are no match for Nui Rama.
He's only got one mask.
Oh, well, he'll beat you anyway.
Uh, what happens if I just do that?
You're mine, Makuta.
I have failed.
Get away, rodent.
Ah, the super family has defeated me.
Get away.
Freak.
Very.
Hello, and welcome to the awards of the super family.
I am Dr. Sinear, and we are back at the AC.
Is this thing on?
Hello, I am Dr. Sinear, back at the AC.
I am going to tell you about...
The...
No, I am going to...
We are here at the awards to celebrate the Tohunga and the Bohrok
for their heroic efforts against Makuta and saving us.
Without them, the world would have been conquered,
and let's just say it all depended on the Bohrok and the Tohunga.
The Tohunga spirit and the Bohrok spirit kept us alive.
Now, we will go honor them.
As you know, we are...
No.
We now give you Aku Aku to tell you about the awards.
Of course...
Of course, he is on Crash's face because he does not have hands.
It's a tiki mask.
Bohrok, we bring you to the awards today
to tell you of the heroic efforts of the Bohrok.
Now, I understand that the Bandicoot is holding me
and the microphone.
Now, let's go to the awards.
Hold me higher, please.
Let's go to the awards.
The first being inaugurated in is Wakoto.
Welcome to the Super Family, Wakoto.
This thing doesn't fit around my neck.
Next being inaugurated in, Niji.
Good job, Niji.
Next being sworn in, Makiti.
Welcome to the Super Family, Makiti.
This thing doesn't fit around my neck.
The first Bohrok in, Korok.
Good job.
Korok.
Next being inaugurated in, it's Leibok.
It doesn't fit around my neck.
I know this thing isn't going to fit around my neck, though.
Next in, Nubok.
Good job, Nubok.
Next in, it's Porok.
Good job, Porok.
Next, it's Galak.
Very good job, Galak.
You only have one Karana, but you're one of the toughest.
Thanks.
And last, but certainly not least, Tanak.
Very good job, Tanak.
Do you have any smaller sizes?
No.
Who are you going to be?
It's Dr. Senor.
And I'd like to tell you that...
And we're in a real hurry here.
Um, uh...
Join us in our next video.
The bonus video of the Super Family's first movie.
Oh, here you are, sweetie.
See you in the next video.
Come on.
You want to help me roll up the microphone?
Want to help me unplug it?
Gotta take the attachment off the, um...
Off the microphone while we...
Pick it up.
You know that, right?
Yeah.
Can I?
No.
No, no.
I wanna!
No.
I wanna.
No!
Pull it up, everybody.
I mean, never mind.
Keep going.
Just clean up.
Camera's not on.
I have to cancel that.
I have to...
Yeah, I have to come on.
Yeah, I'll meet you on Sunday.
P-Pine Street.
Sunday.
Okay.
I'm on Sunday at Pine Street.
Can you drop me off at the corner of Pine Street?
Sure.
On Sunday.
Thanks.
And I hope she doesn't get anything out.
Then she's a pee.
You'll be comfortable with our roomy chairs, and, uh...
We have many choices.
And while you're at Kmart, pick up my garden tools and plants.
Get to Kmart and get outside.
There's always been one special place every parent loves to share with their kids.